It's like this.
It's like past like this.
It's 6 out of 10.
We're not saving out of 10 or getting anything out of it.
It's like that.
They'll get to it, they go.
But because of 4, or not knowing how you're holding the ball,
what's driving the ball, what things are important,
what things are useless.
Okay, the other 3 are like this.
Alright, so we're going to get into this bill over here.
It's going to be shorter.
It's only 1 meter.
It's like this.
It's how the past is going to be.
It's really cool.
It's like this.
We get really catching the ball.
And we get to the room in the ball.
And try and get the train load from here.
I mean, when we extend it a little bit.
So you're here.
And the ball hits the mark all the time.
You see the chance they're doing the target that you hit.
Yeah, you don't have to get all.
It's not easy on the 70s.
The square, because this guy wants to take my hit off here.
I'm here.
I'm going to square it to my van.
Come again.
And we're not following the class.
I'm not following him.
Because he'll kill me.
Because he sees this.
Alright, that's easy.
That's just an ambush credit sign.
Alright, push it on that.
Tony, this C rib.
C rib, deep rib.
Oh, they caught.
Yep, I like that.
I just learned something today.
A question's on it.
Anybody having trouble with their passing?
We're having trouble passing one way.
Yeah.
Tony.
It's okay.
Can you go to see what it's doing?
And you're going to break this.
You've got to understand the mechanics of the just a ball.
And help how it's going to get there.
How you can get that power.
And just come off later.
Right.
If I wanted to get your head.
Think it's going up to the head.
Just what I just made.
I'll coach that.
Right.
I want to go to text.
I'll talk down here.
Right.
I'm a little bit congested.
Because I'm short.
And he's just gave me that right.
To be.
So when the buffalo is coming to get me.
I'll get the pass away.
And I'm already kind of really firm.
Thanks.
Thank you.
I'll put Drake.
And we're over to.
Thank you.